[Music]
there's nothing crazy
hello people it is December 13
2022 I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report and if I had to see Justin
Trudeau singing Bohemian Rhapsody but
you had to see it too you owe me a thank
you because we cut it short it was just
a little nibble that we gave you it's
horrible and we're going to be doing a
little bit of Justin Trudeau kind of
stuff I know I know we've been focusing
really hardcore on Elon and the Twitter
thing so we're gonna take a little bit
of a break from that today we're doing a
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a I
think there is some couple questions
related to the Twitter situation but I
wanted to just start completely away
from any of that today because there was
a few clips of Trudeau that uh I think
are making the rounds right now and just
show the utter hypocrisy and vapidness
of this clown and then on and then I
happen to see having nothing to do with
that I happen to see this clip of Robin
Williams and man wouldn't it be great if
Robin Williams was still around what a
shame and a incredible talent that we
lost too soon making fun of Joe Biden
back in 2009 I saw this on the Twitter
machine and I thought it would be fun
thing to talk about with you guys and
how we need comedy especially in times
like this one of the things that has
happened over the last couple years
we've basically decimated comedy there's
so few funny shows out there because
everyone's afraid to be Politically
Incorrect and say anything true and then
you know Netflix there's that that
woman's comedy special where she her the
whole point was not to make anyone laugh
like it's all whacked out so we're gonna
do a little comedy a little Justin
Trudeau some Community Q a then we'll go
on our happy way all right first let me
talk to you guys about Bonner private
wine you know for 200 years a few small
families deep in the Andes Mountains
have been making a dark red wine unlike
anything you've ever tasted these wines
are made in such small quantities many
wouldn't normally make it to the US but
the guys over at Bonner private wine
partnership have partnered with these
families to bring this never before
imported wine to Wine lovers in the U.S
today I've arranged special access for
my audience to be among the first
Americans to reserve this rare supply of
extreme altitude wine visit
bonnerprivatewines.com David you'll get
top quality extreme altitude wine for a
huge discount perfect for any holiday
meal with the family and if you order
today you'll not only get a huge
discount and complimentary shipping
you'll also get a bonus bottle of small
batch limited production wine from their
exclusive seller that's four bottles for
the price of three just visit
bonnerprivatewines.com Dave to get your
wine today and now back to me all right
let's go back to the year 2009 when
comedy used to be funny here's Robin
Williams a legendary comedian Robin
Williams on then Vice President Joe
Biden we still have comedy though we
still have great comedy out there
there's always Ramblin Joe Biden what
the [ __ ]
Joe said even people tourettes go no
no
what is going on
Joe is like your uncle who's on a new
drug and hasn't got the dosage right
I'm proud to work with Barack America
he's not a superhero you idiot come here
when SDR was on television there was no
TV back then come here Joe sit down man
he went too early didn't he he really
did uh I thought it was just funny and
Worth showing you that because that was
back in
2009 that's 13 years ago and already
people were talking about Joe's
flummoxed confusion and screwing up
words and names and everything else
Flash Forward 13 years and here we are
and he's the elderly man pretending to
be president but I thought we would
compare uh making fun of Joe Biden and
Joe Biden is certainly worth making fun
of uh to the guy up north Justin Trudeau
and you know my feelings about Justin
Trudeau and the important thing is that
in America we're allowed to make fun of
our presidents we're allowed to make fun
of our Senators and Congress people we
have the First Amendment and although
the government has been encroaching on
it through big Tech we still can make
fun of these people and uh this is a
heck of a segue but I just thought it
was important that I made fun of Justin
Trudeau right now here's Justin Trudeau
saying Canada is a place of free
expression
[Music]
as you can also see Canada is a place of
free expression where individuals and
communities are free to express
themselves openly and strongly and we
thank them for sharing their
perspectives merciful
oh you soulless lizard man that is the
same Justin Trudeau who as you know was
closing down Trucker's bank accounts
calling half the country racist and
transphobic because they were trying to
get their stores and schools open and
churches and other places of worship etc
etc but this guy as far as I can tell
has no human soul that he can go up
there and constantly say the exact
opposite of what his actions would prove
that he's for free speech and it's so
wonderful that we have free speech here
when he crashes down on the people that
try to exercise their free speech so it
should not surprise you that Justin
Trudeau does want to regulate big Tech
because you know people are saying mean
things are you willing to go with
regulating social media companies and
what do you say to those who think that
it's an attempt to stifle free speech I
think we've seen that that the impact
that social media particularly around
hate speech around intolerance around
incitement to violence is a real problem
in our communities we need to always
walk that careful balance between
respecting rights to free expression and
free speech and keeping our communities
safe and unfortunately what happens in
the virtual world sometimes spills over
into the real world and I think it's
really important that social media
companies understand their
responsibility to uh to shape and to
ensure that our communities stay safe
for everyone prime minister is just such
a vapid nothing it's not really a social
media's company's responsibility to do
anything other than make product make a
product that event hopefully makes the
the founders some cash and employs a
bunch of people and puts out a good
valuable thing in your pocket on this
thing right that's what a tech company
is supposed to do now we'd like people
to be a little bit nicer online I
suppose as I always say you can block or
mute or just not look at your phone
um but you know he conflates three
things there first off he talks about
hate speech now first from an American
perspective and of course he's the prime
minister of Canada but from an American
perspective there is no such thing as
hate speech the Supreme Court has
litigated on this and if you are going
to have free speech then you can't have
something called hate speech right
because one person's free speech is
another person's hate speech so we do
not from an American perspective have
hate speech now of course Canada does
not have the protections around speech
that we have in the United States it's
one of the things really that and I
would say the Second Amendment the first
and second amendment our ability to
speak freely in our ability to own
weapons are the things that are keeping
us from going off that Cliff that Canada
seems to be going off of this
authoritarian uh Cliff so he talks about
hate speech then he also talks about
intolerance people are going to be
intolerant it's just how it is it's just
how it is Justin Trudeau I find you
rather intolerant of half of Canada uh
and certainly anyone that believes in
the things that I believe in so if I had
the power should I ban you do you see
that this is a two-way street and you
could be uh you could be screwing
yourself once you go down that road and
then finally he talks about in sight to
violence now that's something right so
again I'll do this from an American
perspective there's no such thing as
hate speech you can say mean things
about people it's just how it is I don't
like you very much okay you could say it
uh then there is intolerance people are
going to be intolerant a certain amount
of people are not going to like trans
people a certain amount of people are
not gonna let white people it's just how
it is it's part of the human condition
and the best you can do is try to
explain to people that they should not
be intolerant right that would be
something now the insight to violence is
different because that
is a direct violation of the law you
cannot say and I want you to go there
and kill those people I want you to go
violently harass this person
etc etc but he purposely conflates all
these things because ultimately of
course what does he want I mean it's
very obvious the guy wants to have
control of the internet he wants to have
control over Canadians ability to
communicate with each other he wants to
pretend that he's for free speech and
for free expression while he crashes
down on protesters who are going against
his authoritarian tactics you guys get
it is there a Canadian Robin Williams
they had John Candy they don't have John
Candy anymore who's out there doing
comedy at a Canadian level that's funny
these days I'd like to find that person
and talk to them dad said it's pretty
good but he's not a Kim he's not a
comedian he's just a evolutionary
biologist who hides under his desk it's
a long story if you haven't seen those
videos we should post one uh all right
let me talk to you about guys about Cozy
Earth and then we're going to get to the
Community Q a are you looking to score a
few extra points by giving the perfect
gift this holiday season I've got two
great ideas certain to have family and
friends bragging about how thoughtful
you are and they're both from cozy Earth
the brand with thousands of five star
reviews including mine first cozy Earth
luxury bedding I own a set of these
sheets and you can't believe how soft
they are they're not only super soft but
they're made from the finest premium
viscous from highly sustainable bamboo
that makes them naturally temperature
regulating so you'll sleep comfortably
year round I sure do and second anything
from their luxurious loungewear
collection including soft and stylish
bamboo pajamas joggers tees and more I
love the sweatpants while you're there
check out their premium plush and Waffle
bath towels but you'll love those too
and every cozy Earth bedding item comes
in a cool reusable Canvas Bag save 40
now on cozy earth hurry holiday offer
ends soon go to cozyearth.com Dave and
save 40 That's cozyearth.com Dave
cozier.com
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
here we go Nick says uh Tulsi has not
stated any future political aspirations
Beyond her podcast
but do you think that the increasing
Mass exited uh Mass Exodus of Democrats
like her and Kristen Cinema will make it
more likely for independent party
candidates to win elections look as far
as I can tell right now we are just
stuck in this duopoly and there are
actual decent reasons that it's okay and
then there are there are a lot of facets
of it that are not okay on one hand you
could say that having just Democrats and
Republicans it keeps the sort of Center
like the okay this is this this is this
like we've got two basic paths and they
meet occasionally and nobody can go too
far off the deep end that would be some
argument I don't know that you can fully
argue that anymore because the left has
gone so bananas that they've dragged
everybody in that direction but you know
it's sort of it's like a very kind of
like simple way of looking at politics
you have Republicans and Democrats and
we have this or this this or this and
maybe that that binary choice is one of
the things that's making us all sort of
crazy but there is something to be said
about two political parties not having
to worry about a coalition and and that
you're you're hopefully pushing as many
people towards the center with limited
choices something like that but then
there are governments all over Europe uh
that have these coalitions and I just
had Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
netanyahuan who has for many times now
because he's been prime minister for
many many years had to create these
coalitions so people don't just vote for
the right-leaning party or the
left-leaning party there's all these
different parties then the Coalition
comes in has to get a minimum amount of
seats to run the parliament in their
case it's 61 seats out of 120 and then
you have a government
there's problems with that because if
you're the party that has two seats but
you're getting the Coalition over from
59 to 61 you have an awful lot of
disproportionate power that's why their
governments keep falling so it's all
tough but uh as far as Tulsi and Kirsten
Cinema
the idea that they are you know in
essence leaving the Democrat Party is
good I think that there is a lot of
opportunity to work with Republicans
right now I really do as you guys know
last week I went to DC to talk to the
new Congressional Republicans like
they're eager to be better than their
predecessors I think that they've really
learned a lot partially from Ron
DeSantis here in Florida about what
leadership is and picking the right
fights I think there's a sense even now
Kevin McCarthy who most likely will be
the the majority leader like he seems
like he's getting a little backbone as
Joe Biden would say he's got a backbone
like a ramrod whatever the hell that
means so like I think there is something
kind of good coming but the spirit of
people that are that are Independents
truly and oh I take a little bit from
here and a little bit from here I think
that that's great I just think that
there's a lot more room to work with
those people if you're going to do it on
the right rather than on the left where
I just think there's there's scorched
Earth there's not much left bobi says
hey Dave I hope you're feeling better I
am completely fine I had covered I was
fine the only reason I took the test was
because of the kids I had a little
scratchy throat it's all good thank you
very much do you think fauci will face
any legal action because of his
flip-flop decisions on masks and
lockdowns Dr Burke admitted in her book
that they were encouraging Trump to lock
down the country should she be called in
to testify that fauci did want lockdowns
right so fauci has taken every position
on this he has said many times I wasn't
for lockdowns and then there's plenty of
video saying that he was and I didn't
want to keep kids out of school and yes
he did and masks work and then he's
emailing friends to say that they don't
work like he's some he deserves whatever
he gets I suppose although unfortunately
I think he's probably just going to get
a big pension and and that'll be it look
if it's proven without question that he
lied under oath to Rand Paul about gain
of function or what NIH was doing
etc etc if you lie under oath to
Congress or the Senate then then you're
in trouble and you have to be in trouble
right it's one thing as I always say
it's one thing to lie to his CNN
journalist it's one thing to lie to me
it's one thing to lie to you but if you
lie under oath then there has to be
repercussions for that and fauci has
really uh
not only has been one of the prime
purveyors of this dishonest streak that
we have in this country right now but
the way he's gaslighting everybody to
say that no I didn't say any of the
things that I said but do I have great
faith that something will happen to him
probably not it's just not how the
system works uh Jazzy says good morning
Dave how many psychiatrists or
psychologists do you think are actually
good do you feel they're all
contributing to our downfall well I
don't know that I can give you a number
on that but I would say generally
speaking um you know we have a very very
at the psychiatrist level I'll do that
one first because obviously there's a
difference between a psychiatrist and a
psychologist at a psychiatrist level you
know the people that are prescribing the
pills we have a deeply deeply deeply
over uh drug Society there's just no
doubt about that everyone's got ADHD
everyone's got you know this attention
deficit disorder and that thing and the
other one and restless leg syndrome and
[ __ ] whatever and that we drug
everybody I do not think that that is
good there's an entire industry around
that and then they they come with all
these side effects and then you see the
commercial with the depressed guy
walking around with the little cartoon
you know Cloud hanging over him and then
what does he do he takes another pill
because of the side effects of the other
pill it's not good as for psychology
um I think there's some decent
psychologists out there I think mostly
if people just get off themselves
that sounded dirty
but what I mean by that is mostly uh you
should take some responsibility for your
life start putting some of your like
innate beliefs that little party that
knows what's good and true start
following that thing a little bit more
and then some of the other like General
craziness won't get you I think that's
also partly why over the two plus years
of covid people who were a little more
connected to belief
seem to be a little bit better because
they were believing in something outside
of themselves as opposed to the whole
system which on any given day was
telling you so many crazy things and so
many conflicting things that if you only
believe in that that you are bound to go
crazy and then need to be medicated or
need to lay on a couch with a
psychologist you know for five hours a
week but if you believe in something
else if there's something outside of
what's immediately Happening Here I
think that that lends itself to being a
little bit saner Chuck says if you had
to pick one of your childhood toys to
introduce to the boys which one would
you pick and why Chuck we did a little
Advanced research on this one I went
into the closet and we busted out
this is old sound wave from the original
Transformers I got this thing in I think
1984. it was my uh what was that that
was my eighth birthday baby this is
sound wave who of course he was a
cassette player who then transforms into
a robot who had an awesome his head fell
off I gotta we got a deal we got some
glue around here so sound on his head
like that that sound wave and then
inside sound wave you press the button
the button doesn't really work anymore
now you got ravage he's the cassette
player who transforms into a panther
pretty freaking awesome but I got this
on my birthday 1984 June 26 1984 and
then he was also sitting in there I know
you asked me for one toy that I want to
show the kids but also in that little
box I have my original Boba Fett
the original Boba Fett okay
and an original
[Music]
Storm Shadow GI Joe and as you can see
old school his crotch is totally blown
out that's what happens legs doesn't
have it doesn't have much going anymore
but he's still roughly in one piece but
I can't wait to get them into that stuff
like when they're into like toys and
whatever it is at the time hopefully
Transformers are still around a GI Joe
or maybe some Star Wars stuff even like
yeah I can't wait for that uh Kathy says
I know you have a Tesla how many miles
can you get from one charge are there
public places you can charge your car or
do you have to charge at home how's the
maintenance I'll do the maintenance
first maintenance is incredible I've had
uh we had a three year lease on a Tesla
now we're into a fourth year I guess at
this point I've never had a problem with
the car we had one little cracked
something they came here and replaced it
that's it so the maintenance is actually
super clean and easy and all that stuff
like just it just doesn't seem to have
problems as for the charge
it depends you know if you're on the
highway going super fast the battery
does drain a bit quicker so like I've
driven across Florida across Alligator
Alley and we do have to charge once like
pretty much when you get to the other
coast basically uh but I just I
absolutely love the Tesla having
everything else that's going on in the
world right now I love the fact that I'm
supporting Elon Musk in a very small way
so that's that's nice too but it's just
a super cool car and once you start
driving it you really do feel like
you've there it's just a different level
than driving a regular car I get it that
they're not cheap and it's ridiculous
that the government's always trying to
push people into electric cars but it's
a really really freaking cool vehicle
and uh and if you can get one give it a
go and yes we have a little charger here
at home so I mostly just charge the
thing at night that's it but you know if
you go to stores they have or hotels
sometimes you know they'll charge you
overnight or whatever it might be and
Tesla has these superchargers throughout
the nation so you could literally I
could leave my house from Miami this
morning I could put in an address and
say Los Angeles not that I'm going back
to LA anytime soon it'll tell you
exactly where you have to start where
what you'll need in terms of getting the
juice at that point and where you have
to go all the way uh along your path
Zionist says when you were in DC
recently did you get the sense from your
interviewees that they understand that
the American people want action and not
just more boring wasteful endless
hearings I did I did I sort of
referenced this earlier
um I sense that the Republicans are
going to be a little more aggressive
that they are going to push back in the
way that Ron DeSantis has pushed back
that they they have an opportunity here
where they didn't quite get the wave
that they wanted but they did get the
house now Cinema leaves she's no longer
a Democrat so that's good on the Senate
side like there's a little bit of
momentum there and they have to do some
stuff with it you've got two years to do
some stuff with it and and you know at
this point with the Biden Administration
we all kind of know what it it's far
more left than most people thought it's
seemingly far more incompetent it's it's
extremely radical it's colluding with
the government it sounds you like it
screwed up the economy God knows what
they'll do with the Ukraine war like
they've done like a whole bunch of stuff
but they really did not pay for it at
The Ballot Box and that I think has more
to do with the fact that people just
still aren't sure what our Republicans
are are they Trump Republicans Maga
Republicans America First Republicans is
there something that's a little more
traditionally Republican like what does
that battle look like
um and you also have to just take into
account
the fact that a certain amount of people
are just brainwashed and they just think
that these people are racist and bigots
no matter what so you just should lean
in that's what I that's what I told them
in my uh in my speech last week it's
like lean into the culture wars not not
because you're trying to create a war
but because that's where the freaking
thing is being fought you know what I
mean the Free Speech Wars uh those are
important they're not like purely
political like you know we're we had 72
Senators vote for this and 36 well it's
not that it's like free speech is
important everyone gets that fight for
free speech fight for keeping uh the CDC
and the NIH out of your kids schools
like fight for the right things and I
think you'll be rewarded uh Ben says so
are the Dave's going to have a Britney
law for the boys at the same time or
will it be done by age so Britney law I
believe is the bris which we did at
eight days for each of them I think you
might mean the bar mitzvah which will be
when they're 13 and then they become a
man I just watched the episode of
Seinfeld the other day where the kid he
became a man then he wanted to kiss
Elaine and she wouldn't do it so he
renounced his Judaism we are going to uh
that's the plan the kids will have bar
mitzvahs they will I had a bar mitzvah
my father had a boyfriend my father's
father did going back lots of thousands
of years and uh yeah hopefully we'll do
our best to incorporate that into their
lives uh Florida man says with a few
States re-implimate re-implementing mask
mandates while the rest of the country
is complete really open and free do you
think the people will eventually Revolt
or are they just sitting around begging
to be governed harder so I don't know
where there is absolute mandatory mask
situations right of this moment but we
covered it yesterday it looks like La is
about to bring them back
um at this point
if you don't realize that you should be
responsible for yourself and your family
and that's basically the extent of what
you can do
um I don't know what to tell you but if
you live in LA and you about you not
only did you maybe vote this stuff in
but even if you didn't vote this stuff
in but you participate in the LIE the
nonsense that masks work or whatever
else it is that they're going to do or
they're going to start closing schools
down again it's like
it's on you if you're still there I know
that sucks and I know everybody's got
their own issues related to why they can
or cannot move and you've been there for
a long time and your family's there and
you got kids or you got elderly parents
and all those things but it's not going
to get better you gotta understand all
of the Bad actors almost almost without
exception that's what was so crazy about
it almost without exception
the Bad actors the people who did the
most Draconian stuff Whitmer hochul
Newsome Etc they all got reelected so
what message was sent to them you know
that night boy I did all that stuff
they seem to like it I guess I'll do it
again like that is what they will do and
because
science has become so cult-like you know
if you question these people you're out
on your butt they don't want that turned
around on them so they are going to just
continue to do it they really really
will uh Amy says I bought my husband a
bottle of Clase Azul for Christmas very
nice but what are some other good
sipping Tequilas you would recommend I'm
so proud of my tequila uh selection
right now we've got a lot of good stuff
there is one I wrote it down because I
just had a bottle of it the other day
it's Fort alizella I want to say right
fortalezella
f-o-r-t-a-l-e-z-a a whole bunch of
people had mentioned Fort lazella to me
over the last couple months because I do
talk about tequila on the show and fordo
Lizella apparently is made like the old
school way that they made tequila
literally like 200 years ago and it was
really really clean and smooth I had the
reposado it wasn't crazy expensive maybe
55 60 bucks for the for the bottle
and I really really enjoyed it uh corzo
is another one that I've been enjoying
it's a little kind of a little more
commercial but it's got a nice cool
Sleek bottle and kind of simple but the
Clase Azul let me in when you're when
you're feeling good and you got a couple
bucks in your pocket like you just
cannot beat it you cannot beat it we're
having our big uh our big Reuben report
holiday party here on Thursday night and
I just bought did you guys see it
downstairs I bought the massive bottle
it's 400 bucks
yeah you can each have one sit one sit
breach skinny says should I have been
permanently banned on Twitter a few
weeks ago for saying there is no such
thing as trans men and trans women only
men and women who suffer from mental
illness well so you were banned I take
it that was probably before uh before
Elon took over should you have been
banned for that of course not you're
allowed to have feelings about things
you're allowed to have thoughts about
things you're allowed to make jokes
about things or at least that's the way
it used to be
um so no you should not be banned for
those things if someone does not like
that statement then let them block you
or mute you or ignore you Etc but you
should be allowed to say such
controversial things meanwhile did you
see the story we didn't even cover this
this story about the nuclear waste guy
you know we've got this like polysexual
or what is he he she pup woman dude
who's like the nuclear waste guy and he
gets in dresses and he hangs out with
Rachel Levine and it turns out that he
stole a couple women's luggage bags from
the airport and he was just wandering
around with them for months like what
what
CS says hey Dave I'm buying a new house
and thinking of doing a month-long
unplug can you recommend a good safe for
hiding a phone I don't even know what
our safe is it's just kind of a generic
safe but but do it man well first off
congrats on the new home and as far as
uh the the Off the Grid thing do it if
you can I mean try if you want do it
with me in August and we'll get more and
more people to to do it I know the the
community will be a little uh like a
ghost town but I you know it's one of
the things that has kept me okay
throughout all of this it really is we
are all on an endless
you know hamster
wheel and we're just going and going and
going all the time and it gets harder
and harder to get off that thing and I
think by doing that every month it's
just given me enough space
just enough perspective you know just
enough room to think about things a
little bit differently understand that
boy it feels like an awful lot you know
you take one day off the machines and
you're like oh my God what did I miss
but then you know you take five days off
and you go all right all right all right
I'm still here two weeks I'm still here
a month wow The World Keeps spinning
bad stuff is going to happen good
stuff's gonna happen and
it's still happening one way or another
so why not try it for yourself and and
feel some of that calmness and reset and
give your brain a break I mean we just
don't know what these things are doing
to us we just don't know
uh Eamon says what underrated tool or
tools are indispensable for your job I
was thinking about this one tools I
can't refer to you two as tools can I
that's not that that wouldn't be fair uh
tools
I do like the Sharpie I feel the Sharpie
is the key to my whole operation I
scribble a lot on my papers during the
show I draw a lot of concentric circles
and play Tic-Tac-Toe with myself I like
the Sharpie rather than just a regular
pen even if I'm just writing notes or
you know if I'm just scribbling
something down at night I keep a
notebook by my nightstand just with some
ideas and you know I'm trying to like
piece together another book and what I
would want to do and sketch it together
I've always liked the Sharpie now don't
inhale the Sharpie not good not good
summer says uh what are some good
non-personal Twitter accounts that you
follow non-personal
uh I would say there's one well this guy
mazemore who is a great great Meme Maker
we play a lot of our open cold opens and
cold closes or from maze more he just
does a great job uh of just finding like
all of the stuff all of the lies and
exposing all the nonsense so that's
m-a-z-e-m-o-o-r-e if I'm not mistaken
maze more and there's another account
called clown World which is just like
people doing stupid things you know
[ __ ] sticking their fingers in an
electric socket or some idiot putting
their head you know down the the path of
a subway train and get their head
knocked off you know that kind of
hilarious stuff I like those two those
are big ones and lives of tick tock I
guess that's not personal but you know
she's doing an incredible job all this
woman does with Libs of tick tock is
literally find the crazy people usually
gender related teachers who are saying
insane things about what they're doing
to their students she just reposts them
sometimes without even commentary and
people calls that people call that hate
speech and she was one of the most
censored people on Twitter as revealed
by the Twitter files and it's like all
she did was repost the stuff usually
people post things online because they
want it reposted so it tells you a
little bit about the psychology what's
going on over there Big Poppy says will
the revelations of the Twitter files
actually lead to anything other than I
knew it see they were colluding I mean
that's the question that's the question
and that's also sort of relative to the
uh earlier question about what are the
Republicans going to do it's like we
have these smoking guns now and it's
like if Jack Dorsey specifically because
he's the easiest one to choose here
because he was the one that was
testifying under oath as the CEO of
Twitter and now we have this information
from Twitter Zuckerberg's done it at a
Facebook level we don't have the
Facebook files yet if he absolutely lied
under oath to Rand Paul to Ted Cruz
whoever it might be
you got to pay you got to pay otherwise
nothing matters we can have these
hearings and I think that's really in
essence what your question is like we
have these dog and pony shows we have
these hearings and you're like oh Ted
Cruz really got him we're all that
moment look at the way Rand Paul
destroyed fauci and I've played plenty
of those things but unless something
happens to these people unless it has
some teeth some meaning that eventually
it's like well then what's the point of
the show
what's the point why are we paying
attention to these things I and that's
what I really think is going to change
with the Republicans I think they're
realizing that this is not normal
politics anymore two and a half years
after covid's still going through this
nonsense watching the the gaslighting of
the American people the censorship of
all of us it's like if you guys don't do
anything here then as I often say uh you
don't have to be a republican but you
can't be a Democrat it's like at that
point if we go two more years this and
nothing's come out of anything then you
can't really be a republican either and
then they will have left they will have
left us with a a whole new thing that
we'll have to think about uh Elizabeth
says do you and David have any special
plans or holiday traditions that you're
looking forward to sharing with each
other and or the boys well I can't wait
for Christmas you know we've been
working uh really hard this year
obviously my whole team and everybody
and having having two babies and it's
just been like a lot around here so
having a little time off together just
to kind of be in the house and like
enjoy join ourselves and especially now
Justin's four months Luke's two months
Luke is just now coming into himself a
little bit more so you can he can I can
like kind of move him around a little
bit more and he's like a little more fun
Justin was kind of there early on uh but
my my folks are coming down that week
and my brother's coming with his wife
and three kids and my sister and her
three kids are all down here so
hopefully just all get together and
enjoy some good food and relax and uh
and not be on this thing that much and
enjoy life and I hope that's that's what
you guys will be doing as well as always
guys if you have not subscribed at
rumble.com
Reuben report and if you want to play
along and submit questions you can do
that at
reubenreport.locals.com
and we leave you this one's painful too
we're really just bludgeoning these
people we leave you with Hillary Clinton
and some other chicks singing Goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
walk out the door
just turn around
cause you're not welcome anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
I Will Survive